joining us now former texas governor
former energy secretary rick perry our
friend i was down at the border a number
of years ago with you
um as bad as it was then it's for us now
uh we've had governor abbott on the
program a lot of times he's
called up the national guard he's
allocated three billion dollars in texas
funds texas taxpayers paying
he's actually created miles of his own
wall using patrol cars from law
enforcement
and he's at every step of the way his
battle is really with the federal
government aiding and abetting the law
breaking what other options does the
governor have at this point
sean let me just say one thing before we
get off on to that thank you for telling
the american people the truth
as i
uh flip through channels it's really
difficult to find the truth about what's
going on on the southern border this is
a devastating wave that's hitting our
southern border this administration is
lying about it and i think it's really
important uh that that you and and your
network
others
tell the truth and hold joe biden
accountable hold my arcus accountable i
mean they're literally looking in the
face of the american people and lying to
them about what's going on on that
southern border
families who are being devastated
because of this and
you know
maybe what we ought to do is just hire
every bus
that we can we can hire in the state of
texas
hire uh every uh
charter aircraft
bring the national guard c-130s to the
border and load these individuals up and
take them to maryland
and leave them there and maybe leave
them at lafayette
you're hitting on something important
here governor
or secretary i don't know what you i
don't know which you prefer whatever
title you like you own them all
but but the important thing is is once
they're here and joe lets them in
we don't have the ability to deport them
because that's supposed to be the role
of the federal government to enforce the
law they don't do it then they disperse
people high rate of covert positivity no
test no vaccine mandate all around the
country and then
people come without any money then
states bear the burden of food and
shelter and education and health care
and we can we can't balance our budget
governor it's not it's not complicated
math here
well but the all of this big
infrastructure bill is not going to cost
anything i mean i heard that president
look into the camera and say this is
going to cost zero and
sean that's lying to the american people
i mean he's playing americans for chumps
uh and and people who voted for him they
need to really
take a deep breath think about what this
individual is doing to this country uh
it is staggering what's happening
along that border uh the you know those
have historically been democrat voters
in those counties along the rio grande
i'll tell you one thing uh they're
rethinking that today and they're
looking at uh joe biden and going this
is
potentially the biggest mistake we ever
made in our lives to let this individual
become the president of the united
states i'll add to that abandoning
americans in afghanistan when he said he
wouldn't governor perry we always
appreciate having you on thank you sir
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis